hey francis do you want to keep your
online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i
secretly watch bbc comedy embarrassing
that's why you need surf shark vpn how
can shark surf
shut up surfshark is a virtual private
network available as an
easy to use app and browser extension
that lets you place your laptop or phone
anywhere in the world allowing you to
access the internet as if you were in
another country
this means i can access a whole host of
websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that
you can protect your online identity by
masking your true ip address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's
great value for money because one
surfshark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 percent off plus three extra months
for free
surfshark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below and use
our code
trigonometry to get 83 off
plus three extra months for free
we're telling white kids that you know
you're racist you need to have
unconscious bias training because
whether you're overtly racist or
subconsciously racist you are a racist
because you're white and all white
people are racist and that's a given
at this point how are we accepting that
as a given fact anyone can be racist
anyone can be a victim of racism
that's a fundamental basic fact that we
need to get back to
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today is a
former teacher turned political
commentator calvin robinson welcome to
trigonometry it's an absolute pleasure
to be here in person thank you very much
it's great to have you on man uh listen
uh you've been doing the rounds
lately and uh we like people who piss a
lot of people off and you i think are
right at the top of that list at the
moment you're doing well
uh but for anyone who isn't familiar
with your background your story
because as i was saying to you before a
lot of people will see you popping up
and talking about
some of the things we'll go on to talk
about but uh
they might not be familiar with your
backstory so tell us who are you
how are you where you are have you ended
up sitting here talking to us
good question so i think first of all
you said i pissed a lot of people off
and
i find that fascinating because to me
i'm just speaking normal
common sense british values the things
that i was brought up
understanding were what normal people
think i don't try to be extreme i don't
try to be
a controvers or anything like that i
just kind of speak my mind
so my background is i'm from the
midlands a small town called mansfield
in nottinghamshire
former miners town very working class
background
white mother black father my father's
family are from from jamaica
they came over here during the windrush
generation so i've got a lot of
experience in uh
what you call racism
i was trying to think of a better way of
playing it but you know growing up in a
as
one of the first black families in a
very white town i experienced first-hand
how bad racism can be in this country
which is what leads me quite often to
discuss racism
uh in public because i don't think a lot
of the time what we're talking about is
racism there are a lot of other socio
economic problems in our society a lot
of other causes going on and people see
racism everywhere
but i got involved in politics because
essentially you know growing up
in a single parent household after my
parents split
my mother worked really really hard all
of her life to put you know food on the
table for me my sister
she's a role model absolutely um but
people around us
weren't working as hard as my mother you
know people staying at home on benefits
and being better off
than my mother who was you know she's a
she's a lecturer now
but she always worked at least two jobs
and i thought something is wrong with
our system
if people are better off not
contributing to society and and people
are kind of trapped almost at home
there's a system where people are
dependent on the states
that's not what the welfare system
should be about in my opinion it should
be there as a safety net for people who
really need it
but we should encourage people to go out
and work and earn a living and
get some meaning in their lives and
contribute to wider society and i don't
think that's what we have
at the moment so that's what drove me
into into politics and into
conservative politics uh so to speak uh
you know
growing up in a former minus town it was
probably quite controversial to have
conservative opinions people aren't
necessarily
fans of margaret thatcher up there but
you know but a lot of them do think with
small c values
even though they don't label it that way
and i think that's the same up and down
the country most people in this country
are normal smallsy conservative people
that don't want this woke agenda being
shoved down their throats all the time
which again is another thing that i talk
about
but as i entered politics i always said
i will never talk about race i don't
want to be that guy who goes that mixed
race guy who gets shoveled on to talk
about race all the time
but it's just such an issue and i feel
like you know we talk about privilege
quite
a lot and one of my privileges is that
i'm able to have this conversation
without people
casting aspersions and naturally
assuming that i'm racist or
for the most part anyway i'm able to say
things that the average straight white
male isn't allowed to stay in this
country anymore
so i feel like i'm duty-bound to stand
up and say them which is the reason i
stick my head above the parapet so often
and often get it chopped off and you say
you were
able to say the things that a straight
mike male is not able to say so what are
those things calvin
that for example somebody look like me
wouldn't be able to say
thankfully yeah in my voice this isn't a
systemically racist country that this is
a fantastic place to live one of the
best places in the world to live
actually
it's the most tolerant diverse inclusive
country
in the world and that's why people
choose to live here and people come here
um and make a success of themselves and
that's fantastic and we should celebrate
that but instead we focus on the
negatives
and we look at our society and every
single problem we pin it down to race
these days and it's not like i said
earlier i've experienced real racism i'm
not discounting people's
personal lived experiences but what i'm
saying is if you look for racism
everywhere
of course you'll begin to see it and
i i have a real problem with you know
the way we're teaching young people that
everything is racist and everyone is
racist as a former teacher
you know i see all the time this this
self-perpetuating myth of
white supremacy you know telling young
people that
if you're black or of an ethnic minority
background you are going to have hurdles
to overcome
there are barriers that people are
putting up in your life because of the
color of your skin
but isn't that true isn't that true even
in the way you've described your own
story you talk about growing up in a
mixed race family
in the midlands being the victim of
racism or
whatever experiencing race or maybe
victims the wrong word but
that that would have been a barrier in
your way surely someone being rude to
you or offensive or
you know causing problems at school or
whatever it might have been
would that not have been an extra hurdle
that your white classmates wouldn't have
had to deal with
no and it depends where we're talking
about so it wouldn't have been an extra
hurdle because
as much as people were offensive to me
and caused me upset
that wasn't people being discriminated
against me so it wasn't when i went for
it to apply for a job they were saying
no because you're brown
that was people calling me a [ __ ] in the
street and that's purely ignorance on
their part because that is the wrong
derogatory term
but also it doesn't mean just because i
got racially abused because i was
one of the few brown people in a white
town doesn't mean that white people
can't get racially abused too and i work
in london schools for example where
white kids tend to be in the minority
actually and i see a lot of the racism
that goes on in london is towards
white people these days so anyone can be
a victim of racism
and we've got to get back to the
reclaim our language you know racism
means discrimination or prejudice
against someone
because of their ethnicity it doesn't
mean a power struggle between black
people and white people
that's you know that's what the work of
try to readjust our language to kind of
win the battle by default we've got to
take the terms back and put
put meaning behind our words again and i
think a lot of white people at the
moment
are experiencing racism i think
anti-white racism is the most popular
racism after anti-semitism at the moment
it's so fashionable to be anti-white and
it's it's
it's acceptable you can talk about the
white man as much as you like and no one
will blink an eyelid
you know no one will raise an eyebrow
it's completely okay and i don't get
why that is we talk about you know
institutional racism and and and black
people being oppressed i don't feel
oppressed yes i experienced racism as a
child at points
but in my in my adult life i don't feel
oppressed
uh in this metropolitan city this
capital that we live in i don't feel
oppressed but i do
see oppression all around me all the
time and that is people oppressing the
white man
you're not allowed to speak up if you're
white you're not allowed to have an
opinion if you're white you're not
allowed to
engage in these conversations if you're
white how is that not oppression
and also we talk about the fact that you
know we live in this
liberal you know metropolitan bubble but
why is it acceptable calvin that if you
deviate from the standard rhetoric
as a mixed-race book as a as a black guy
and you say well i disagree with this
why is it
then acceptable for somebody to use
racial epithets against you
well exactly because this i'm preaching
for equality i hated
being the victim of and i don't like
that word but the victim of racism or
experiencing racism
i don't want anyone to experience racism
whether they're black white asian it
doesn't matter to me
that's what equality means that nobody
should experience that
but the moment i stand up and say that i
get accused of being a race traitor
i get called an uncle tom a [ __ ] a house
[ __ ] all of these horrible
derogatory racist terms and people again
think i'm fair game because i'm not
subscribing to their approved narrative
and it's very much
a form of control like they don't feel
like they control me therefore i am
against them therefore i'm a bad guy and
they can call me whatever the hell they
like
it baffles me how someone can consider
themselves an anti-racist
while being racist towards people like
me and
who are the types of people who make
these claims who and who say these
things to you
do they come from a standard part the
argument political spectrum
race gender etc well it tends to be
people on the hard left and
quite often it tends to be other people
of ethnic minority status so other black
and asian people
mostly it's other black people that call
me things like house negro but i have
been called that recently by
a bangladeshi woman which is fascinating
for me because that is clearly then
racism
but it was still accepted
and so it comes from this
you know stepping away like i say from
the approved narrative is
it is the establishment's opinion that
we need to protect
ethnic minorities and i get where
they're coming from that's that's a very
well intentioned thing to want to
protect people but i think it's
patronizing
i think we need to treat all people
equally we don't need to treat people
special in a special way
because they happen to have brown skin
and that's where it all comes from
i think this perceived racism this you
know
if people don't happen to get where they
want to be in life they'll blame it on
systemic racism if people
don't get a job they'll blame it on
racism if people don't
um well if people don't get anything at
this point people are living very
entitled lives i think
and it's easy to pass on that excuse but
i don't think it's their fault
i don't think people are thinking you
know oh i'll blame that on racism i
think
they've been taught this from a young
age
and you know we've talked about this in
the past and i know you've had other
guests
because i was a governor at michaela
school for example with catherine
burbleson
which she founded but schools liked that
and you know while i was in school
i've i tried to teach all young people
that it doesn't matter where you come
from
doesn't matter what your background is
what your race is we're all here
together we're british that's the thing
that unites us
that's our community and if you work
hard
keep your head in your books you'll be
able to make a success of your life
whereas a lot of other schools
especially in the state sector in this
country are teaching young people that
actually
you know what you're a victim like i
said earlier you've got hurdles to
overcome you've got barriers
and that is self-perpetuating because
the more you tell young people that the
more they'll start to believe it
and on the other end of the spectrum
we're telling white kids that you know
you're racist
you need to have unconscious bias
training because whether you're overtly
racist or subconsciously racist you are
a racist because you're white and all
white people are racist and that's a
given
at this point how are we accepting that
as a given fact anyone can be racist
anyone can be a victim of racism that's
a fundamental basic fact that we need to
get back to
why is it so taboo for somebody of your
ethnicity
to be conservative in this country
so where my father's family are from but
okay
most people are conservative you know
the labour party over there is a
conservative party
where is this sorry might have jamaica
jamaica yeah so my father's family from
jamaica the labour party over there is a
conservative party despite the weird
name
uh most people in the caribbean are most
people in africa are small c
conservative it's just in this country
and and in america actually that the
left have taken ownership of bmes
of black and ethnic minorities i don't
know why i use that term i hate that
homogeneous term but they've taken
ownership of us to
take control over us they've said if you
vo if you don't vote for us you ain't
black or
we will help you unleash your potential
that's the the biden and the corbyn
message that is you know
you are one of us uh we're here to
protect you and they do that on purpose
because they want our votes whereas
they're not looking after our interests
and
you know i am a small c conservative
because i believe that the family unit
is the
basic fundamental um
beacon of society and once we lose the
family we have a breakdown
in our systems in our way of life and
that's why we're seeing such
light you know rises in life crime in
london that's why everything is falling
apart because we've lost
faith and we've lost family and those
are the two fundamentals of our society
that we've kind of
let the left break apart but that's the
reason i am a small c conservative but
saying that for some reason sets me
apart from
the left and where they perceive black
people to be or
where they think we should be i don't
know that bme term is interesting isn't
it because i i often think it's just
another way
of just saying those [ __ ] over there
isn't it really well it is
it's another term for non-whites and
yeah again it's pinning people against
each other it's divisive it's toxic it's
saying you are either white
or you're not right you're one of us or
you're not one of us and if you're not
one of us we need to help you we need to
support you we need to patronize you
and that's not true but think of the
what i'm getting
is think of the the massive amount of
variety or that word diversity
within that group the idea that you can
put indian people with pakistani they're
fighting the [ __ ] nuclear war over
there right
they're not the same they don't have the
same views or values or attitudes or
heritage or education or any of that
and then you take afro-caribbean people
like yourself and then people who come
first generation immigrants from africa
the differences between those
groups are sometimes bigger than the
differences between a white british
person and a black british person
100 they couldn't be more diametrically
opposed so again from my education
perspective we see black african
children excelling throughout school
through primary school through secondary
school they're doing a lot better than
every other demographic pretty much
especially white british kids
and black caribbean kids white british
kids and black caribbean kids are
almost at the bottom of the scale
there's only uh
travelers and gypsies that are actually
below them um and black african kids are
twice as likely to go to university so
it's not a case of you know systemic
racism because if it is
people are picking apart black kids and
saying or
we'll treat the african kids different
to the caribbean kids i don't think most
people would even see the difference to
be honest with you
um i think what's happening what's
happening here is a difference in values
and again it comes down to
family and faith and african families
tend to still have their faith and tend
to still
see the families important and we've had
a breakdown unfortunately in the
caribbean communities of family
we have a massive issue with
fatherlessness and there's a lack of
faith there
these days as well which we wouldn't see
if we went back to you know the
caribbean and we see a lot more faith
than we do in caribbean british
caribbean families
uh which is which is a shame uh and
that's the same with
white british the family issue is
is what's happened breakdown in the
family and the breakdown in faith can i
just say before you ask your question i
think we're setting some kind of record
for the number of racial slurs that have
been
answered in the course of this
conversation
i mean yeah it's it's he is don't you
come out with one man
well my mom's brown anyway because
that's not going to help me it's not
it's not a
look how pink you are already like it's
just not good it's equality if we're
allowed to say something he's allowed to
say something
if he's not allowed to say something
neither are we go for it's from the
caribbean
america i've always where's my support
i've always wanted to do this show by
myself
i'll go for it where's my anyway um
can you get cancelled any further at
this point probably not let's try it
that's fine
but calvin here's the thing do you think
that there have been some scars
inflicted upon the british caribbean
community because they came here during
wind rush
they endured that racism that inequality
that open hostility whilst a lot of
first generation for instance
african families who come here in 2010
11
they're not going to be exposed to that
as well as much of that because
we're quite literally a different
society than we were back then
it's an interesting perspective but i
don't think it's true i think you know
when my grandparents came over here
they really really relished the
opportunity to come over here during
windrush they celebrated it they wanted
to become brits
and they were proud to be commonwealth
citizens and all of that
and yes they experienced a lot of racism
but we have made progress
i often say you know my father
experienced a lot less racism than his
father and i experienced a lot less than
him doesn't mean we didn't experience
any and it doesn't mean that we don't
need to still work on it but we've come
a long way
and i think the generation after me the
young kids that we see today
especially in inner city schools and
london schools where they are no longer
the minority
and they're no longer experiencing
racism
especially not on the level of people
from the windows generation what we're
seeing is
a loss of identity so for example my
grandparents
while they were proud to be become
british they were also proud to be
jamaican
and my father being born born here he's
proud to be half british half jamaican
whereas the you know we're getting to
the third and fourth generations now
where people are like okay so what
is my identity how should i identify and
what we've what we're missing is
you know in schools for example we don't
promote british values the teaching
standards say don't undermine the
british values and i think if we
promoted them
and gave something for people to latch
on to then they'd have that sense of
belonging that every single human being
needs but because they don't have that
they get and they're getting told
left right and center that the color of
their skin is the core of their identity
they're like so what does that mean what
does it mean to be black british or
black caribbean british
this day and age it doesn't really mean
anything because caribbean people
integrated into british society very
well there is no segregation there
whatsoever
whereas in america which is where they
often look there is
there's a completely different
environment you know african americans
are a community
and there was a lot of segregation in
america and they had a lot of race riots
and they only
just reached a level of well there's
just about reaching a level of equality
whereas we've had that so when our young
people are looking to american culture
hip-hop culture african-american culture
all of that and taking it on board
they're addressing issues and seeing
issues that don't necessarily affect
us and we saw that with black lives
matter over last summer where you know
kids in london were fighting against
police brutality we don't have police
brutality in this country
they're saying you know take your knee
off my neck and and
you know get rid of police guns and very
few police have guns over here you know
there's there's no issue with
with police racism in the uk it's it's
completely
a case of us importing us drama and
that's
that's because our kids are so lost and
they don't have an identity it's
interesting that
you keep coming back to british valleys
and i'm working on my first book and it
will be
largely about west needing to stand up
for itself and remember what its values
are
but i was we were discussing it the
other day actually and you are
probably second maybe to catherine
berbel seeing who you used to work with
you are our two most patriotic guests i
would say
in the entire history of the show in
terms of being openly
talking about you know british you know
catherine talks about having a british
flag at the school and
and teaching kids british values and
reminding and i think
that really as we become more and more a
multi-ethnic society
if we don't do that part of it oh that
is not a good
path to go down is it 100 and you put
the nail on the head right there with
a multi-ethnic society that's what we
should be striving to achieve a
multi-ethnic society not a multicultural
society
we've kind of diluted our own values
under the premise of inclusivity
we don't really understand what
inclusivity means and we kind of think
it means okay everyone is welcome
and we'll take all your values on board
and dilute our own because we don't want
to offend you we don't want to be seen
as
anti whatever you are so we'll take your
values on board and we've lost our own
sense of value we've lost british values
along the way
because we've been so afraid of
offending people and so afraid of
affirming our own values and we need to
like you say stand up for our own values
again and say yeah it's fine
to be proud to be british this is a
fantastic place to live like i say this
is why so many people are coming to live
here it's an amazing country
with an amazing history and good values
you know and
when we say people say so what does that
mean what are british values and i say
well
whatever you think they mean it is an
intangible thing on one level but
on the other level the government did
try to pin them down and they said you
know
tolerance of people of other faiths and
non um
democracy the rule of law and these are
things that we celebrate
and these are things that again people
come back at me and say well but calvin
they're not exclusive to britain and i'm
like well
when no one's saying they're exclusively
ours but i can certainly name a few
countries that wouldn't celebrate these
you know that's why they're so important
to us we helped spread parliamentary
democracy around the world
and again people will talk about the
empire and say oh we were the
evil british empire but there's so much
we've lost a sense of context and we've
lost a sense of balance there was so
much good that came out of that as well
even me saying that i'm probably gonna
get canceled just for saying that now
it's absolutely ridiculous that you
can't have a balanced conversation
but you know we help spread
parliamentary democracy we spread
christianity we help spread schools and
hospitals and charities
and the english language for goodness
sake um a lot of good
came out of it but also a lot of
atrocities that we should absolutely
address and we should teach
history holistically i'm not denying
that but let's not try and paint
everything in a binary picture of black
and white and
automatically stick with the negative
you know it's it's usually our
intellectuals as well that are so quick
to denounce british values and british
culture
as a bad thing uh for the world and you
know western values as well and just say
the west is evil and bad you're like
well not really you know if you're
not relatively speaking and a lot of you
look at what's happening in the rest of
the world
and even this last year or so with
what's happening with with
with the coronavirus people are afraid
to criticize china in any way shape or
form
but if they did anything if we did
anything rather like what they're doing
over there with the uganda muslims
uh the atrocities the genocide if we did
anything like that they'd be so quick to
denounce it so why are they afraid of
looking outwardly it's cultural
relativism it's it's their culture
chinese people are supposed to put each
other into
some money that's how these but i think
it's partializing i think of course
it's because they're foreign yeah they
don't understand things like we do
they're not they're not
our level they're not as liberal as us
yeah so we can't expect that of them no
absolutely we can of course we can
we should expect every country to have
you know a basic level of human rights
and decency towards other people
unless we do trade with them in which
case you crack on that
we still want your your cheaply made
crap over here calvin let me ask you
this
moving on slightly although it's similar
subject and i've asked this question of
dozens of our guests and all have given
their own version of it
but you're someone who's been very
particularly coming from the educational
background that you do
you're someone who seems to me to have a
very kind of precise and nailed down
definition of this
can you explain to an ordinary person
who's just picked up a newspaper and
they're reading about crt for the 73rd
time without really knowing what it is
and frankly i put myself in that camp i
think about these issues very carefully
but if you ask me constantin can you
define what crt is in two sentences on
live television
i'd probably struggle right so first of
all before we get into talking about it
what is critical race theory so critical
race theory is the idea that
white people have some kind of privilege
and black people are
naturally oppressed based on the color
of their skin
that's that's it in a sentence but then
people will come back and say no what
we're actually saying is that you know
you won't be discriminated against
because of the color of your skin if
you're white that's what white privilege
means and
even that isn't true because like i say
i've worked in a lot of london schools
and i've seen a lot of white kids be
bullied because they're white
and you know in if you take that to a
wider issue we can address the grooming
gangs well we've had
a survivor of that yeah so it absolutely
is possible for anyone to be
discriminated against based on the color
of their skin that is what racism is
um so i don't think white privilege is a
thing i think white working class
kids and working class people in
particular have been left behind in this
country
and almost forgotten about because it's
unfashionable to address the situation
if you say you want to support white
working-class kids
or white working-class people in general
you are going to be perceived as a
racist what do you have against brown
kids why don't you want to help the
black kids all the asian kids
and it's not about picking who you want
to help it's about looking at who's not
doing well
and trying to level the playing field
and we do that by
introducing equality and stop treating
brown and asian kids differently
stop treating black kids differently
based on the color of the skin that's
the only reason why kids are left behind
it's not because we're not addressing
them it's because we're too busy
addressing other people
if we treated all kids equally across
the board and raised our standards for
everyone all kids will thrive and that's
the same in society same issue in
society that we see in schools
and why is it that suddenly you know i
understand to a certain extent these
ideas become popular in academia
but why is it they get filtered down
into our education system
we've got enough of a battle trying to
get kids to read and write
and be actually literate by the time
they come out to school
why are we filling their heads with this
stuff it's because well-meaning
individuals want to make a difference
and they want to be seen to be doing the
right thing
on one level and there's some on some
level there's people that want to be
virtually signaling and showing everyone
else how much of a good person they are
and the way to do that is to say that
you are an anti-racist or to say that
you believe that black people are
oppressed in this country and that this
country is systemically racist
but if you ask anyone in what way is
this country systemically racist in what
way are you held back by the color of
your skin
very rarely will you get an answer you
know people will say well
the nhs is racist or the police are
racist or education's racist i'm like
okay give me a prime example
i like people to give me examples in
education just because that's my field
but they never ever can
and the only thing they ever say to me
is well i look in the textbooks and i
don't see people that look like me
but that's just illogical because this
is a country that's been predominantly
white
throughout its entire history of course
most people in british history will have
white faces
but that doesn't mean you can't learn
from them unless you are racist and you
can learn from people that look like you
so that's quite an interesting take and
then people say but i want
representation i want to see more people
that look like me
i respond well be that person then be
that role model for other people if
representation is important to you
and you are you know superficial
diversity is an important
issue for you then be the brown face
that's doing you know computer science
or whatever
field you want to go into and be a role
model for other people but i don't think
superficial diversity is important i
don't think we should be focusing on the
skin color of people i think we should
be looking at what they've achieved and
what they've brought to our society
you know people like tim berners-lee who
invented the internet the world wide web
uh people like that we should be
celebrating as british icons
and we're not able to because he happens
to be white so we have to look for some
you know someone who's brown and in
education again we would talk about
replacing people like mozart on the
curriculum with stormzy
mozart who happened to influence music
the way we compose music the way we
think about music
for decades stormzy who has a popular
song
shut up shut up rude boy shut up not
quite on the same level
but he happens to be brown and popular
so of course let's let's put him on the
curriculum
it's to me it's bonkers and this is the
fundamental problem with what's going on
in
society at the moment it's all
topsy-turvy and i think most people
see the world the way that we do in a in
a normal way but
we've been taken over almost by the woke
mob the virtue signalers who want to be
seen to be doing the right thing and
want to be seen to be
uh good people in the eyes of each other
and they are the vocal minority
and you know this is why you know the
beginning you said to me you pissed a
lot of people off and i
i'm genuinely just talking normal common
sense values as far as i see i'm not
trying to be
controversial so well it's the same with
us we don't we don't even necessarily
advocate any specific set of values we
just talk to different people
about them and we piss people off from
doing it but i was going to ask you
do you think um your mixed race
background
informs some of your views where you
have
you know your mum is white so when
people talk about
the white people being the oppressor
you're not thinking about a generic
category you're thinking probably i
would imagine of your mom
and you're going well my mom's not going
around oppressing people in fact she
raised me
do you know what i mean does that inform
your thoughts on this issue it does
sometimes it's interesting because
being mixed race means i'm not white
therefore in most people's eyes i'm just
black so people disregard
half of my heritage half of my
background half of my upbringing
half of my skin color which i found to
be quite a level of racism actually
in the why if you're not 100 white
are you therefore by default black yeah
um
so it does affect my world view in that
being mixed race
i have a lot of people in my family that
are black and a lot of people in my
family that are white
and on both sides have experienced
racism which is why i know that anyone
can experience racism
but also it affects me that a lot of
black people who are racist towards me
are kind of upset on some level because
i'm not 100
black and i'm not 100 white
they've i don't know it's i think
bisexual people have the same issue
they have a lot of animosity towards i
love the way he looked at you
but this is what i hear anyway yeah and
i think it's like people
want so badly to categorize you to put
you in a box if you don't fit in that
box
they don't know how to deal with you and
they see you as a problem something to
handle
i'm not a problem but i think if we
really really push this british values
thing
and move the conversation away from skin
color like morgan freeman says stop
talking about it that's the way to get
rid of racism
eventually i reckon we'll probably all
end up being beige anyway as we
you know as society progresses and it
will become less of an issue
but yeah i think it has on some level
but not on a conscious level affected
the way i think about things
it's a very interesting point you make
so i
weirdly classify myself as mixed race
mother's latin american grandfather was
an arab
you know i looked like my father i got
my father's irish skin
but one of the questions and one of the
things that coming from two completely
different cultures and i don't know if
you've experienced this
is that you know you never truly feel
neither one nor the other
you always feel somehow on the outside
because you are always you can connect
with one culture but there's always
something a little
bit different because of the experiences
that you've had with another culture
do you ever find that no because i see
my culture as british
entirely i'm half white half black but
100 british
because my mother's british my father's
british
yes they have um they they have
different bringing different elements of
culture into it but my culture is
british so my mother's for example from
the midlands
um she'll say help me docurate and you
know we have
certain dishes up there and certain
customs up there that wouldn't
you wouldn't see in london that's part
of her culture whereas my father he has
you know
um jamaican dishes and he'll say what
i don't know he wouldn't say that but
you know what i mean so they have
different dialects
they have different recipes dishes
different food types different uh
cultural norms
but bring those together what unites
them both is
britishness in my in my opinion so i
don't have a
a problem with my identity that is that
is the core of my identity after my
faith
and everything else comes secondary to
that and you talk about your faith and
you're a christian
yeah and why do you think your faith is
so important to you
uh so many reasons but i think
what faith does is it takes us out of
ourselves and i think we've got a very
selfish society at the moment
and christian values and british values
used to be about service
and duty and community and family
and putting others before yourself um
and i think we've lost a lot of that and
all of that stuff would really help us
at the moment actually
people are always striving for personal
happiness whatever makes them happy as
an individual i am all for people living
individual lives and being individuals
but we do have to at some point consider
society
if we want it to survive and if we want
it to be meaningful
and do you think part of the crisis that
we're seeing is actually the fact that
we don't have faith
anymore we don't have a belief in god
100 so if we look at what's happening
for example with
extinction rebellion black lives matter
all of these
really extreme hard left groups people
are latching onto them because they
don't have a faith anymore they don't
have a religion but that leaves people
with a void
they need a belief structure and if we
look at what these things are doing they
are like cult you know extinction
rebellion have
vestments and all these blood cult
things that they do in the streets
and black lives matter have their chance
and
they are filling a void for people that
people need something spiritual in their
lives and if you don't see it
in your faith then you reach out
wherever it is being given
and at the moment it's these extremist
left-wing groups that are saying come
join us we'll give you a sense of
belonging will give you a sense of
purpose
and the god that they worship is
themselves
and that's rather unfortunate have you
ever been abroad and felt
out of place because you didn't speak
the language no because i voted brexit
brexit means brexit i know that
sometimes you're abroad you don't speak
the local language it's very awkward
like france is talking to a woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babble is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have daily 10 to 15
minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe
you find it difficult to pick up or
maybe you're just english
right now babel is offering our fans six
months free on a six-month subscription
with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger
that's babble b a b b
e l dot co dot u k
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babble dot co
dot uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
well speaking of bringing people
together there's there
used to be an institution that was
designed in this country
to some extent to do that to create a
common
uh culture you know in terms of comedy
politics like
the way he's responding to i'm talking
of course about the bbc
uh you're not a fan of the bbc
i used to be you know when john benjamin
talked about churches and
and uh kenneth clark did his
civilization
and when the bbc used to put out content
that no one else could do
but now they're not doing that anymore
they they've become a commercial entity
in and of themselves
they're not producing anything that any
other station couldn't produce
um they're made some of that work comedy
you have to get a taxpayer to pay for
that [ __ ] that's a good point but i mean
what are they doing that's unique you
know they're supposed to inform educate
how are they doing either of those
things bbc world service
you can argue the world service is great
but is that enough to pay 160 pounds a
year for
i think what we need to do is look at
what the bbc does well and then it will
enable them to do that
without us having to pay a tv tax so the
remit
used to work when they first came about
they were one of well they were at the
early station at the time but then they
became one of only two or four stations
it made sense uh for things to work
their way they did but now we're paying
the bbc for the privilege of watching
any other
live television whether the bbc's had an
input in that or not that doesn't make
logical sense to me
first and foremost but then the content
that the bbc does put out is entirely
woke
you know everything is about social
justice issues everything is about
lecturing the british public on how they
should think what they should be saying
what they shouldn't be saying what's no
longer appropriate to think or say
or do and i don't i don't think people
like that i don't think people like
being elected to by
one particular perspective at all times
there's no balance there there's no
conversation or debate
it is just this is our view this is the
appropriate
approved view that everyone should be
subscribing to and if you're not you're
a bad person
and that's why we're seeing wow curry
everywhere because it's perpetuated from
bbc from channel 4 from itv all of
mainstream media is on it at this point
but the difference is that we have to
pay for the bbc and look
okay calvin here is a reason why i
still want the bbc to exist okay
we need something in the center which
brings people from left
from right conservatives libertarian all
the rest of it
where they can come where we can share
ideas or we can talk
because otherwise if we don't have that
then what we end up with is america with
people
on their individual little stations
talking to each other we create echo
chambers we're just going to exacerbate
you know the polarization in society
and ultimately arguably bring polar you
know
bring the downfall to society because we
won't be able to communicate
i mean you're right on so many levels
but i don't think that's what the bbc
does
it well it does bring people together
from the left and right in the you know
as part of our defunder bbc campaign we
hear from people on the right saying the
bbc is so left wing
and people on the left saying the bbc is
so right wing and it's not it's just
metropolitan liberally they have their
own political perspective
and it it annoys everybody so they do
bring people together in that respect
but they don't bring us together for
debate or conversation how many
right-wing comedians do we see on the
bbc
jeff norcot yeah
this is the problem isn't it i mean in
fairness that argument is slightly more
complicated than that because
uh i'm neither francis or i are right
wing
but depends who you are depend on
according to some people were
right of course just because we talked
to you mate
that's that's how that works but there
are not many right-wing comedians and
that's
in that's nonsense there's loads on
youtube and on
twitter and instagram i'm not saying
they don't exist i'm saying if you look
at
the body of the comedy industry the vast
majority of comedians are not right wing
and so if you have fewer people then
you're going to end up with fewer people
making it to the top because
statistically there's going to be a
small percentage who are good enough
so the reason you don't see a lot of
right-wing comedians on the bbc partly
but only partly and this is important as
a new one's point
is because there's not a lot of them
around yeah there's not a lot of them
around
having said that uh that what i would
argue is the bbc
is definitely biased against them as
well and it's biased against other
people who are just simply
not woke that's to me more more more the
drawing line but i i think
just in the same way that we should be
careful when we talk about
representation
in terms of race we should also be
careful in that just because there's
some kind of disparity in outcome
doesn't mean there's discrimination
going on
necessarily um so i i think that's an
important point to make
you know i i'm sort of with francis but
also with you because
i feel very woke about the bbc and i
don't care about reality i just care
about how i feel
and i i just have that hope that it
could be the vehicle that brings people
together my concern is actually
technology
young people don't watch the bbc so
is it even going to be around 50 years
from now do young people not watch the
one show
there's so much breakdown in that i do
want to address the diversity things
yeah let us talk about that just because
i'm not saying there should be quotas of
how many right-wing people are on the
bbc i i don't believe in diversity
quotas i think that they're fraud
but what i'm saying is they're
addressing diversity in other ways that
are making the issue worse
so they're spending 100 million pounds a
year on you know making sure they have
more brown faces
more brown faces that think alike to me
that's a problem um
at the same time as charging us all
extra for our license fee at the same
time as
now charging over 75s for their license
fee so they're willing to splash out
money on superficial diversity that
makes no difference
while at the same time chasing us for
money but um what's your second point
about oh you want them to exist
absolutely in theory i like the theory
it's like communism it's great in theory
is it though i'm all for the bbc
existing i'm not saying it needs to be
gone completely i'm saying we need to
loosen the reins if they want to be work
let them be woke but don't make me pay
for it
so maybe they should have a different
business model where they get revenue on
a
on a global marketplace or something i
don't know if they think their content
is worthy enough people pay for it
shortly
i don't feel like forced under threat of
prosecution to pay for it i
totally understand that argument and we
hear it all the time and i totally get
it
i just worry calvin that once you get
rid of it
you've you you're crossing the rubicon
and
there's literally no way back my hope is
like
all this woke [ __ ] settles down 10 years
from now
and then the bbc kind of goes actually
we've got it a bit wrong
let's actually make content that
everyone can enjoy you know i mean like
you can sit with your you know slightly
racist grandfather and you woke pink
haired 18 year old and they can all
enjoy a show together yeah
do you know what i mean i know what you
mean i just don't know if we're heading
in that direction no we're not heading
in that direction absolutely not there's
a new nonsense every day isn't there
there's a new
career every single day i i could sit
here and listen i'm sure you guys could
but unless i see us heading in the other
direction i don't see anyone taking
the direction at the moment i don't
think the government's really addressing
the work issue the cultural
wars if you if you want to call them
that i don't know who is
so we are it's left down to the three of
us well exactly but this is the problem
are we big enough to take on the bbc and
mainstream media
so maybe we need to do something about
it
do you think that defunding it is the
way to go do you think that is a way to
solve this particular
problem money is always the way to solve
a problem isn't it
cut off their purse strings and they'll
stop doing whatever it is you know
it's like these universities in america
that said they were
institutionally racist and trump said
okay well if you're racist we'll stop
funding you then all of a sudden okay
what we meant it's the same with that i
think if the bbc wants to be completely
woke let them do it but don't make us
fund it
and then if we change their revenue
model i'm sure we'd quite quickly see
them change their programming attitudes
as well
but if you look at most broadcasters
you've just given an example yourself i
mean channel 4 which is partly funded
you've got itv which is you know which
is funded through advertising you said
it's work
netflix is i mean woke as hell so is
um amazon you know if
if we defund it is that really going to
solve anything
yeah but they're competing with each
other aren't they and i think we need to
diversify that talent pool
so i don't think it's that the bbc is
institutionally woke i don't think they
have a
organized system of workloads they just
tend to employ people who think
like themselves that's the problem we
need to somehow diversify that
and we need to hit them where it hurts
in order to wake them up to let them
know that that's an issue
like you say young people aren't
watching the bbc they're tuning into
netflix or they're on youtube
or they're watching tick tock or
snapchat these days
and so they're chasing an audience that
doesn't exist elderly people tend to
watch the bbc
and now they're turning off because none
of the content applies to them it's not
appropriate it doesn't represent them
i mean the inefficiency of the bbc i i
go on the bbc frequently i'm sure you do
as well
i've done work for the bbc you don't no
but my experience there is it's full of
well-meaning people
who just they have a certain mindset and
they just think
oh we'll get constantine in because he's
a weirdo who who has the wrong opinion
and we need one of him
for every 200 people who who who think
like us
so every now and again they'll eject
someone with a different opinion
but broadly speaking they're sort of
just like
it's that diversity thing that they love
to bang on about they just
they have a mindset and they want other
people who think like them
so it's not some kind of evil cabal like
people try and make it out to be but the
incentives aren't there and for the
financial part of it as well is
sort of worrying because you're charging
taxpayers and that money then
becomes completely differently treated
because i've been involved on things on
the bbc and you're going
i'm not sure anyone listened to this
right
maybe it's because i was on i don't know
but or anyone's watched this or anything
anyone's engaged with this
and so i'm sure you get a lot of money
being wasted and it's taxpayer money and
that's
that's a concern isn't it yeah
absolutely it's concerned the few times
i have been on the bbc like you said
i've been the odd one out
and you have you have like a panel of
five people that are completely working
you have
yourself on the corner and they paint
you out as an extremist for having
normal views
that's a problem but yes absolutely the
money is the core issue there in the
they're wasting it on you know these big
well-paid celebrities
and they say we have to compete with the
private sector it's like do you
really because the bbc is a you know
it's a global institution it's got a
respectable reputation a lot of people
want to go work there anyway
you don't have to pay these million
pound salaries in order to get talent
so they're wasting our money on talent
they're wasting our money on diversity
quota rubbish
you know just waist left right and
center so if we say to them
you have to find a different way of
funding yourself going forward we're not
going to let
the public pay you through a television
tax over
threat of prosecution you're gonna have
to find a new model let's see how that
would change things
and what do you say about when people go
look the the bbc
still makes innovative content
you know you look at your attenboroughs
as a classic example
nobody you did have to pick a 97 year
old guy for this example
yeah i mean he's an old white man he has
privileged calvin i realize that
but what i mean it's brilliant isn't it
who does documentaries like that
um netflix um anyone can do a
documentary like that
and anaya who you've had on here has
created a good documentary that's coming
out this summer
lots of people are doing it i don't
think you need to be public publicly
funded in order to create something
unique
um you know channel 4 have a remit to
create things that are different to the
norm as well not that they do that but
you know there are lots of different
organizations that can address these
issues
when you say they're creating good
innovative content and then again you
point to someone who's been
at the bbc for a long time if we think
about people that are trying to create
that kind of content
now such as is it country life or
country file i don't watch the bbc
country far i think it is came out and
said you know the countryside is
institutionally racist and it's it's a
white area
um so as a person who's not white i'm
thinking okay so that does that mean
that countryside isn't for me is the
how is the countryside racist towards me
i've spent a lot of time in the
countryside i find it to be peaceful and
quiet
um there aren't a lot of people there
granted a lot of the people that are
there are white but i don't think it's
because i'm not welcome there it's just
because you know
cities tend to be more metropolitan and
more people i think minority statuses
tend to live in cities but this is just
another example of
anything modern anything contemporary
trying to do what the bbc used to do
has all gone completely woke and it's a
shame
i agree with you do you think maybe just
maybe and this is a hope of mine rather
than a belief
but it is a hope this woke moment that
we're in
it's just one of those periods in time
in human history where everyone looks
back on it
30 40 years later and just because oh
suddenly we had people running around
saying everyone's a communist or
suddenly we had people running around
saying everyone's a witch
we just or suddenly we decided we need
to torture people who don't believe
quite the right kind of christianity
it's just the moment when everybody goes
mad for a bit
and it's important not to overreact
in terms of tearing down institutions
like the bbc in response
no i wish that was the case i really do
so do i i think we've got to stand up
and fight and i mean
everybody because they are they're the
ones looking to tear down our
institutions you know they're ripping
literally ripping down statues left
right
and center you know we've got the new
diversity commission that's been set up
in london
to look at what to tear down next how
horrible is that
they're not they're not going to be
putting up any new statues they're not
going to be honoring anyone
else they're going to be looking at who
they can destroy who they can cancel
next because they're not quite working
off by today's standards
you know this idea of looking at
historical figures by today's standards
is nonsensical because where does that
stop in three years four years five
years when we look back at people from
today are we going to be cancelling them
and that's that's like you know the
issue with the uh the school that came
up last week where they
renamed their houses from lord nelson
and sir walter rally to
marcus rashford and greta thundberg it's
like these are people that are still
alive
still living they could get cancelled
tomorrow if they say the wrong thing
how are you not forward thinking enough
to perceive that you can't keep
adjusting your standards in this way it
doesn't make any sense
i mean obviously greta thundberg is a
bad choice because she's the queen of
truancy so you know
she just didn't go to school enough to
go to school kids go to school kids
um but look on the statue thing let me
let me put a counter point to you
because i'm interested in your answer
more than anything
what is the argument for i grew up in
bristol when i came to this country i
lived in bristol
what is the argument that explains why
the descendants of slaves who were taken
out of africa taken to jamaica and then
maybe some of them came over here
why should they be walking around
looking at a statue of a man who
profited from their ancestors
being murdered raped tortured enslaved
etc
what what possible reason could we have
as a country
for continuing to honor that person by
having their statue and a living human
descendant of slaves
having to look at that has anyone walked
around
anywhere and seen a statue and said oh
my god that offends me
ever i'm not convinced that actually
happens i'm not convinced that people
are offended by statues
i think it's just virtue signaling they
want to show how good they are
and how bad these people were
historically if we look
far back in our history you know if we
keep going back in our history we'll
find a flaw with every single person
nobody was perfect and throughout
history unfortunately slavery was a
thing it was a terrible terrible thing
but it was a thing for a long time so a
lot of people from those periods were
involved in some way in some way or
another in slavery
right but that doesn't mean they didn't
start charities that doesn't mean they
didn't
build hospitals that doesn't mean they
didn't educate kids and when we put
statues up we put statues up in honor of
their accomplishments and their
achievements we don't put them up in
honor of the bad things that they did
you know winston churchill is a great
hero of mine because he
almost single-handedly prevented fascism
on a global scale
you know we wouldn't have entered so i
think the russians might have a couple
of words to say about but we wouldn't
have entered the war if it wasn't for
him i'm not joking of course you're all
right
and we won and he said and did a lot of
horrible things too
but that doesn't negate the fact that he
stood up to fascism and
it's the same across the board we can't
we have to look at people holistically
and we don't put people but
right there are people who objectively
did some things that are so bad that no
matter how well they made the trains run
it just doesn't offset it right so we do
draw a line somewhere don't we
but we only put statues up for people
that have you know
achievements that we should honor we
don't really put statues up for bad
people in general do we
in the lampartar they have a statue of
genghis khan
that's that's a good point you got me
there but now i think what it comes down
to for me is
that if we look at these things
holistically and we don't put them up to
venerate them we're not worshiping these
people
uh they're not saints and even the
saints themselves were not perfect
people they all had past and histories
so we need to look at history entirely
holistically take on both sides of every
argument
and then think did this person
contribute to our society in a way
that's
improved it and got us to where we are
today if they have great
if they haven't there's a conversation
to be had about where you go from there
but i don't think we should be looking
around to say
which bad person can we remove next or
who who had some
remote link to a plantation at some
point in their family tree even if it
was nothing to do with them it's just
bonkers
i do agree with you we've gone too far
but i still
am you know i don't know and i'm the
reason i'm asking you these slightly
provocative questions
is just because i'm trying to work it
out in my head i don't know what the
justification is because
because the the guy in bristol coulson
he he didn't
have a remote link to a plantation his
business was slavery right
so should i i didn't i didn't at all
like the way that that was dealt with at
the time no accountability no
just people come and come along and tear
down the statue to me that's wrong
that should be done through a proper
process but equally
i sort of don't i i struggle to make the
positive case for having a statue of him
erected now
yeah so why should it be up now
maybe you'd like to start a campaign i
don't know but
do you see what i'm saying like if we
wouldn't erect that statue now
should it really be up there now look i
think we should handle these decisions
democratically yeah
that i completely agree with you
completely so if another enough people
are offended by something then there
should be a consultation period and we
should address it
appropriately that's how we should
handle it as for bristol they they're
kings of the world can't they they've
been saying recently that they want to
pay
or the uk should pay reparations to uh
descendants of slavery i'd have no idea
how that would work
because in this system we don't have
government money we have
taxpayer money therefore they're asking
taxpayers to pay
you know people who were never slaves
money from people who were never slave
owners
and that would mean people like you know
me i
my money would be going to pay other
brown people how does that make sense
you know poor brand people would be
paying rich brown people
is absolutely insane your mom would have
to pay your dad which i'm sure she
wouldn't be happy about me but
i think my dad would be paying his dad
too
in this system it doesn't make any sense
i don't think reparations are a logical
uh thing to do but i think also you know
like i said we do have to acknowledge
our history holistically which does mean
saying that you know slavery was bad and
we had a hand to play in that
but it also means that we also pretty
much abolished slavery on a global scale
it was the slavery slavery abolition act
and it was our navy
that put slavery to an end so we should
celebrate our successes as much as we
look towards the uh the negatives
so what we've seen so far is we've seen
you know
the woke movement spread it's got its
tentacles everywhere critical race
theory has now
infiltrated into schools
have we gone too far and is there any
way of running back
we've completely gone too far and there
is a way of rolling back because
thankfully the every man the normal
person
still holds british values traditional
what i would call christian values
and all we need is for them to stand up
and say i've had enough
it's the vocal minority that are the
woke mob
and they are getting their way because
they shout the loudest and they scream
the loudest what we need is for
normal people to stand up and say i've
had enough of this now and
one way i think we should start doing
that is just taking ownership of our
opinions and not being afraid of being
cancelled and i know that's a difficult
thing
it's easy for me for someone like me to
say but i think if people at home you
know
change your avatars on twitter to your
face put your job title if you're a
plumber a builder whatever own it be who
you are
and don't be afraid of them canceling
you because the more people that do that
they can't cancel all of us
and they need to see that we are real
people and these are normal opinions
that we hold we're not extremists for
thinking there are two genders and that
i'm not impressed because of the color
of my skin
we are just normal british people with
normal british opinions
and we only we all need to stick our
heads above the parapets until we reach
a point that that's no longer a thing
and we are you know our opinions become
taken for granted again
as the normality and the work mob kind
of go back into their caves and
and shout at each other and cancel each
other out do you think that's going to
happen
that's what i pray for that's what i
work for that's what that's what i think
you know that's what this is isn't it
yeah it is but
do you think that's gonna happen well
look i mean you you're sort of
interrogating him about it but think
about
our show and you know we've had to take
a lot of flack for starting trigonometry
and for the bigger it gets the more
flack we take but
think how many comedians watch
trigonometry secretly
it's quite a lot yeah you know and so
the same with you
with what you're doing there's a lot of
people who just watch from the sidelines
and they don't want to necessarily get
stuck in but
it's tough advice man because you're
asking people to put their lives on the
line
absolutely and it's hard for a lot and
not everybody you know for us thankfully
because we're creating something that's
of value to other people there's
there's an upside to it and we can
actually have a career
you know after some of the interviews
were put in there now in the next couple
of weeks
uh there's no comedy career left but uh
but there is another career but
you know you're talking about a plumber
you're asking people to put their
livelihood on the line that's tough
that's really really tough but on the
other hand
i also think i completely agree with you
man like
until enough people start to to put
something on the line
um it's not going to change and you know
we had brett weinstein
a while ago talking about this and i was
saying to him well what's you know
you're an evolutionary biologist brett
what's the rationale for someone to risk
their life for this so
weird thing and he sort of said well the
reason you're risking it is not
for for the greater good you're risking
it because your future
is going to be very badly affected
unless this takes a different direction
is that the sort of thing that you think
about well i think it's both isn't it i
think we have to get back to what i
talked about earlier service
and duty towards each other and we have
to
that's a reason to stand up not just
because of our own futures but to
conserve this country and it's
it's legacy and everything that we've
built here we don't want to see it
destroyed by the neo-marxists who want
to break it down and rebuild it in their
image
see the reason i was grilling your
calvin is because i think we're [ __ ]
i think there's a tinderbox yeah it's a
very stressful time right now
and the only parallel i can think of is
brexit so people were feeling you know
disenfranchised and
forgotten and left behind and they spoke
at the ballot box which is what we do
we're very subtle here we don't revolt
in england do we
um so we spoke at the ballot box and
said enough is enough
uh we want to leave the european union
and we don't think that westminster is
listening to us and we elected a load of
brexit party meps for example
and i think we could see something
similar happen again around the culture
wars around
all of these issues that we've talked
about walkery and
and free speech and all of the stuff
that we're concerned about but most
normal people are too on some level
yeah oh of course they are well i was
going to ask you there's a funny thing
that's happening now and i've been
observing it for a while with
uh with arguments about the culture
which sort of works a little bit like
this like
someone on the work side of things will
make a crazy
argument like you know there's a
1347 genders
and you go well actually i don't think
so and they go stop weaponizing the
culture war to attack trap
like there's a sort of brainwashing
thing where people are now starting to
claim that the culture war
is something that is happening to them
yeah why do you think that is
well they're reframing the argument
aren't they it's like you know the
anti-racists call themselves
anti-racists
because it's a good cover and that
enables them to
push their neo-marxist agenda forward
and enable them to be racist to people
like me
um because nobody wants to fight against
someone who's called an anti-racist
because that by default makes you a
racist and that
all that is it's reframing their
argument it's the same with all of this
mercury black lives matter
they were going out there you know in
america they were burning down cities
over here they were you know causing
quite a disturbance a lot of violence
um but their argument black lives matter
is something that you don't want to
argue against that do you of course
black lives matter who would
who differ with that opinion but that's
what they do very well they frame the
debate in a way that makes them look
like the good guys
even if they're doing something bad
because nobody wants to attack the good
guys
well at trigonometry we've always been
against kicking puppies
that's our label therefore anything else
you say about us is completely wrong
calvin great to have you on the show man
thanks for coming on i appreciate you
playing with us and
challenging you a little bit and asking
some provocative questions it's been a
good conversation we've got one more
question for you which is always what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
this is going to be a controversial one
i don't know if i should really say it
but we're not talking about the great
reset
we're not talking about buildback better
this hashtag that's taken over the world
and i'm not a conspiracy theorist
but there is something going on here i
don't want to leave
this horrible pandemic this horrible
lockdown
a different country i want the old
normal i don't want a new normal you
know i don't want to
come out of this in a cashless society
and i'm very
worried about all the things that i'm
hearing um from our government about
hashtag buildback better
i'd like us to return if we want a
better society we can work on it
together we don't want it
implemented for us or on us that is
oppression that is tyranny all right
well in for a penny in for a pound
since you brought it up i mean i think
the monetization went when you said
house negro about 73 times in a row
uh just when you said it then as well
yeah uh but
since you bring it up look i don't know
what the great reset is
someone sent me the link to the world
economic forum i looked on it it just
looks like a bunch of people who are
like
oh we want to end capitalism or whatever
which is fine people are allowed to want
to end capitalism i don't agree with it
right but when you talk about the great
reset
what are you talking about look at the
way he's got his hand over his mouth
i'm not conspiracy theory but 5g
and lizard people lasered people yeah
well it's this idea that you will own
nothing and you will be happy that
really disturbs me and it's not even
against capitalism it's a new form of
capitalism it's this idea that
so we're seeing it already for example i
went to my bank to pay in a check the
other day right
and it's so difficult to do that i tried
to queue up the cashier there's only one
there
they encourage you to go use the
machines i'm a computer scientist i'm
not a luddite but
i don't like everything being automated
because we're losing what we're actually
seeing is the erasure of the working
class
so normal jobs that normal people would
do are now being automated
but that doesn't stop the wealthy still
earning money
so what we're seeing is the class divide
is widening people who are already rich
and successful and powerful will remain
so but they're normal ordinary folk who
did normal ordering jobs their jobs
won't exist very soon
and we we're seeing kobe being used as a
cover to speed up the process we you
know
for example the 45 pound cash limit on
contactless payments been increased to
100 pounds
to increase um to improve the economy
how does that improve the economy
but is that not quite a conspiratorial
thing to say because
you say used as a cover it's perfectly
credible in my view to say
not used as a cover but it's like if
we're paying for if we're trying
to reduce the number of physical
contacts where people can spread disease
doing things contactless sort of makes
sense just as a counter argument that
would be one of the things right
the other thing you talk about the the
you know a ratio of the working class i
get that
completely but it's been already
happening it's pretty much if you listen
to andrew
yang why donald trump got elected right
automation is taking over people's jobs
is that really like people are using
covert
nefariously or is it just like what's
happening it's not nefariously but
they're using it to speed up the process
so why would you open your branches if
it costs you x amount to employ
so many people when you can just have a
machine that you put your check into
and you know you save yourself a lot of
money so people are using kovid now that
when we come out of it we won't have the
same society that we went into it with
that's the problem
and you know i'm really not
conspiratorial but the problem i have
with the world economic forum and this
this great reset is that it's all there
in the open and it is you know
the davos um conference that all the
world leaders go to all the most rich
and powerful people in the world go to
and they
not conspiring behind our backs but
they're talking about this very openly
this idea that they want to change
society they want to improve it
but it's in their image it's not
democratic we're we're not having a
discussion about this it's being
put on us and that's what that's what
scares me that's what worries me and
even raising the issue makes you look
like a tinfoil hat wearing
you know swiveled loon which i am but
not because of this
i'll be honest with you i do think
they're using it as a way to get rid of
cash
and i don't buy the whole oh less
contact well you've just got one central
disease vector
which is a chip and pin yeah and who
benefits from
us having less cash well the government
because they can track you know because
they can track us more effectively
and number two it's it's a way to
control
working class people who pay using cash
indeed but also what i worry about in
the long run
is you know systems like what they have
in china if you do or say the wrong
thing your
your social credit is destroyed and we
say no nothing like that would ever
happen in this country
but talk to me a year ago this time a
year ago i never would have thought we'd
lock down citizens in their homes and
tell them who they're allowed to invite
into their own house
i would have thought that would be a
completely foreign idea so you never
know where we're going to be in
in a year's time never never mind 10
years time that's what petrifies me
about this whole thing
and just to say with our overloads at
youtube we love you
everything you do is brilliant uh and we
won't talk about any of the things that
you don't like to be talked to exactly
and we pray to xi jinping
every night absolutely so thank you for
watching our final video on youtube
it's been an absolute pleasure kevin
robinson thanks for coming
where can people follow you and find out
what you do um at the moment i'm on
twitter at calvin robinson but if big
tech cancels me i'm also on telegram
common sense calvin um just i don't know
read the telegraph or the daily mail
pick up an old-fashioned paper don't
stick to online because big tech are
controlling our lives he says on youtube
calvin thanks for coming on mate and
thank you guys for watching we will see
you very soon with another episode like
this one
uh or a live stream or maybe not after
this conversation who knows
but if they do go out it's 7 p.m uk time
take care and see you in the gulag guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below